[Music]
as a result of this player's history
DDoS activity abusive behavior and poor
sportsmanship the player behavior team
is issued a lifetime ban on Jen Singh
his account has been perma banned and
all future accounts will be perma banned
on site Jensen has consistently
disregarded the letter and spirit of the
summoner's code his disrespect for the
rules of the game is unacceptable for
any player especially a high profile
eSports competitor who has a regular
opportunity to leave the community by
example Nikolay Jensen has become one of
the West's strongest midlaners and
players for one of the league's most
iconic teams unlike some of his
contemporaries the journey he took to
get there was anything but standard
unfortunately we got disqualified as a
team and a few members of the team
including me got banned due to toxic
behavior it's a former World War Craft
arena enthusiast used the alias of ìgod
in his early League of Legends days
Jensen became known for his solo q play
in season 2 especially his 1v1 out plays
and helped found a roster called team
solomid d which included players such as
nuke duck Yamato cannon and Rey Tech if
the team was set to compete in the
qualifiers for the season three European
Championship Series it was the first
split of the LCS in Europe and
qualification was a big deal to earn a
spot in the qualifying rounds the teams
have had to battle their way through the
online qualifiers all placed highly in
those major tournaments throughout the
preseason though competition had existed
for European teams before season 3 it
was never like this this was a major
opportunity unfortunately for Jensen it
wasn't an opportunity he would get a
competitive ruling from Riot Games
banned him from competitive play
indefinitely and team solomid II was
disqualified from the competition
Gamze ruling said that Jensen had
consistently disregarded the letter and
spirit of the summoner's code his
disrespect for the rules of the game is
unacceptable for any player especially a
high profile eSports competitor who has
a regular opportunity to lead the
community by example riot said that
Jensen had publicly and unapologetically
admitted to engaging in a series of DDoS
attacks against high elo players Jensen
admitted to having threatened DDoS in an
interview with into lol shortly
afterwards
but said he never actually did it after
that I felt really down I definitely
learned a lot about myself as a person
not only was his Vai God account banned
but all future accounts belonging to
Jensen would be banned on site as well
it was a lifetime ban in all senses of
the term this was a big departure from
previous riot bans where players like I
will dominate had been allowed a new
start under a different alias which
Jensen was denied Jensen's future as a
competitive player seemed done left
without any real options
Jensen found another way to leave his
mark on the competitive scene though the
exact date is unclear Jensen became the
coach of SK gaming a fact that was
discovered by fans of the competitive
scene though it was not formally
announced at the time the initial ruling
against Jensen has stated that he was
ineligible to compete in the LCS and in
any right affiliated League of Legends
tournaments indefinitely this suspension
shall commence immediately whether
coaching qualified as competition was
unclear in Korea however where worlds
was to be held that year coaching was
already recognised and according to riot
that meant that Jensen was banned from
being officially recognized as a coach
despite the fact that he had already
been part of SK staff if informally up
to that point their explanation he had
been granted access to the EU LCS studio
during season four as a team guest also
team guests would not be allowed four
worlds but according to an AMA he
in October 2014 he had previously
reached an agreement with riot that
allowed him to play the game without the
ban on site provision while he wasn't
allowed to compete his new account so
we'd no longer be targeted as long as he
maintained his behavior Riot Games
banned policy underwent a big change in
late November 2014
instead of permanently banning players
from competitive play and issuing ban on
site orders riot instead changed those
bans to indefinite bans meaning that
they would be reviewable at a later date
if players conduct on their new accounts
was acceptable Jensen was finally
allowed to stream and his band came up
for review under the new policy but
according to riot he did not yet meet
the criteria to be unbanned still riot
said his case would be reviewable five
weeks before the beginning of the LCS
summer split
the surfacing the team he would
eventually join cloud nine had a
rollercoaster spring split in 2015
hi the team's midlaner had long acted as
the primary shot-caller c9 managed a
second-place finish in the spring
playoffs the consecutive wins for Team
solomid the Nexus falls and team solomid
for the 2015 North American League of
Legends Championship Series spring split
champions but hi then step down from the
active roster citing a wrist injury the
roster that had played together since
April 2013 had made its first major move
and Jensen was set to become the first
of a second generation of cloud nine
players after I got unbanned I was lucky
enough to get picked up by cloud 9 I
want the best for c---nine and I'll do
everything I can to help support them
get to where we're supposed to be
a lost boy puts up the box that's gonna
stop the rest of the team cleared
through it to flash body slam on a cargo
box up the hill Baker toss just missing
less point but there should be enough to
take them down
that's incarnation with the living
artillery picking himself up 1 5 2 3
sirens coming in from the backside there
did not see that a cloud 9 force to use
December off to put themselves back in
the fight
there's two freak our nation looking for
a third one actually puts more damage on
the turtle so he cannot stay in the
fight Pearson with a sliver of health
gets out of this one gets behind
incarnation his breath at mid lane
making sure he can make it to the mid
maybe to the leg with his team Dyer is
doing his damndest here to shut down
cloud 9 who already has the head-to-head
against team Sullivan and look to
stretch it just a little bit more 45
minutes on the clock
trying one last time to go for broke on
the stoppage although statistically
Jensen had an above-average season it
became clear that hi had been more than
just the team's min later he was a key
part of their shot calling and strategy
the team sometimes seemed lost without
him
relegation became a real possibility and
the team needed hi back but it wasn't
Jensen who would step aside
it was the jungler meteos is like out
but I think we're trying this the
changed didn't instantly turn cloud nine
around but putting hi in at the jungler
position gave the team enough momentum
to avoid the promotion tournaments
meteos is still a great jungler they
have a bit of a different style where hi
as much more supportive I would say but
the major thing was like the shotcalling
but also hi used to be a mid laner so he
honest stance when I need and he can
like help me much more and it's easier
for him to understand when he have to
help me along after winning a tiebreaker
against team eight they placed seventh
in the regular season
not playoff bound but not facing down
relegation however c9 had earned enough
championship points to make it to the
North American regional gauntlet and
there the team would finally find their
stride
Nexus turret number one where's the
defense it's up there it flows have to
give up the base they give up the game
they give up the series
cloud9 get through first sweep and
they're gonna face Team Liquid this
might be the push to send cloud nine a
world champion 15 seconds here comes
sion and he goes doesn't find a champion
but the turrets are in front already
dominate akes a pine top and a takes the
javelin turret one is gone
turret two under fire piglets up in four
there's the naka but there's the cash in
he takes about quest is dead-on to the
nexus they go double first Nikki piglets
back up a piglet slowed down by some
time Phoenix's body de leyva cannot kill
them off incarnations on the mountain
that's gonna be the Nexus
chef McLeod
Jennsen was a key part of the team's
efforts as they reverse swept both
gravity gaming and team impulse before
winning three and one against Team
Liquid against all odds cloud nine had
made it to worlds Jensen's first season
with the team despite rocky team
dynamics showed flashes of brilliance
and I'm actually pretty surprised at how
Jensen took the games here zero tunings
like iTunes we're going in now we're
gonna win I was like I can appreciate
that so everyone had a very good
mentality for that let's think about
that for a moment in Jensen's past he
had grappled with controlling his
emotions by his own admission he had
been a toxic player but I think I have a
lot to improve on still so I think the
main goal is to be good at for good for
world so we'll see but during his rookie
split one game away from elimination
he chose a different path a bit slow but
I think by the end of the season we will
be the best team he chose to cheer on
his teammates and he had worked Jensen
had become the first permanently band
player to be redeemed I think in the
beginning of the season Jensen was a
little nervous to play had a lot of big
shoes to fill up basically and I don't
know how his team was there to help him
up that much at Worlds cloud9 got off to
a hot start in Group B with three
straight wins the next week they
followed that up with three losses and
then were eliminated in the tiebreaker
by ahq e-sports club
his only victory for AHQ one final dunk
on the other side of the map it's
leggies play space jam and AHQ will be
the final team at a group b the gauntlet
and world's may have been a Cinderella
run for the team but spring 2016 broke
up much of the original cloud 9 roster
hi and balls were moved to cloud 9
challenger meteos return as jungler and
impact was added to the roster as the
new top laner 2016 saw Jensen settle
into his role as c9 starting mid laner
and changed his alias from incarnation
he earned all pro team honors in the
spring split and the team 56 and a
spring playoffs and second in summer
earning another trip to the gauntlet and
yet another trip to Worlds it also set a
new record for kills in a single game he
was a great mid laner last split and it
was up there for people's All Pro
beating him coyote 20 could be on the
board that's number 20 for Jensen as he
goes double digits easily in this game
they're looking for the kills patent a
few of the stats here with smiles on
their faces as they will move on while
Jensen's behavior had been reformed his
signature cockiness remains yeah I would
say I would say I'm pretty cocky when it
comes to game yeah and what is not based
on them just I think knowing you better
thinking you better yeah I would say I
would say it's a mix of both going into
Worlds 2016 Jensen expressed his
intention to defeat Vader in lane on
Twitter and now notorious comment
especially given
if you want to prove yourself you have
to beat faker and that's like one
opportunity I get so that's swirling it
down opening here it doesn't go quick
done he does have hope down c9 before
they fight here and said
[Music]
he says no but the old he's still killed
in else
where'd it leave like island ok turn on
again
faker looking for the old link get the
[ __ ] but wolf I had a couple eat this
the change is here to do so he just
opens up in there get old if I make it
that ultimate easy clean up fake another
kill now the team ultimately went out in
quarterfinals that year and while Jensen
didn't clap faker
he has shown continued improvement over
his time in the NA LCS he was neck and
neck with bjergsen in the spring split
and statistically the best na LCS mid
laner in summer ultimately Jensen showed
us that redemption is possible even for
those who receive some of the harshest
punishments that Riot Games has ever
issued not only that but his route to
that success showed us that he may even
have become a better player and teammate
in the process
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content be sure to hit that
subscribe button
[Music]